faire ici maintenant avec deux vis de la
compagnie des contraire créé en 1991
alors naturellement lincendie de l'arche
en novembre dernier n'allait pas les
arrêter on va couler encore autour la
dalle au jardin en train de préparer et
caetera et nous allons monter un
chapiteau en toile qui était acheté en
belgique qui doit arriver vers le mois
de mars
un chapiteau à 40000 euros financés
grâce à l'aide de la région ile de
france et son enveloppe de cent mille
euros
il viendra s'installer à côté du site
sinistré avec pour objectif de pouvoir
tenir le traditionnel festival annuel de
cirque du 3 ou 5 avril
l'avenir de la culture a mené de la joie
de l'unité de la fraternité et de
respect
ça c'est le futur en attendant la
compagnie des confrères continuent ses
nombreux projets se tuent de mazembé et
au plein coeur de rénover un chantier
d'insertion redonne des couleurs à la
place de l'échauguette avec de la
mosaïque un chantier mené par une
artiste qui travaille avec la compagnie
depuis 16 ans en jeu découvert cette
ville avec noah tomasi et je suis tombée
amoureuse immédiatement pour moi c'était
un petit bout du brésil
toutes ces études ni toutes ces femmes
tous ces enfants de working girl on est
tous assez fantastique depuis trois
semaines ses hommes ont appris l'art de
la mosaïque
un chantier qui rend la ville plus belle
leur apprend de nouvelles compétences et
leur permet de travailler comme mourad
qui enchaîne les missions pour la
compagnie depuis plusieurs années on est
obligé de continuer son contenu sont
s'arrêter baril avait gagné malheureuse
rond chantier d'insertion bret tout à
fait avec béthune farc ont su séparer la
personne qui fait chaud ici pendant que
les morceaux de carreaux se dessine la
compagnie des contraires recherche déjà
de nouveaux projets et continue de ne
regarder que devant elle pour le futur
du quartier de la noé